Myslíme si, že kvantové počítače nám umožní řešit některé problémy rychleji, než dokážeme se samotnými klasickými počítači. Ale
pochopení toho, jak, je jemné. Dnes v Qiskit v učebně se pokusíme odhalit zdroj síly
kvantové výpočetní techniky pohledem na jeden z úplně prvních
algoritmů. Vítej v Qiskit v učebně. V této sérii použijeme Qiskit k prozkoumání některých základních
konceptů běžně probíraných v kurzech souvisejících s kvantovou výpočetní technikou. Každé video je doprovázeno interaktivním modulem
odkazovaným v popisu níže, takže se na to určitě podívej. Pokud jsi o kvantových počítačích hodně slyšel, pravděpodobně jsi
slyšel, že mohou využívat kvantové jevy jako superpozici, provázání a interferenci k řešení
problémů způsoby, které klasické počítače nemohou. Ale jak přesně tyto vlastnosti pomáhají? V roce 1985 byl David Deutsch
prvním, kdo ukázal, jak to může fungovat. Přišel s tím, čemu se nyní říká Deutschův algoritmus, který dokázal vyřešit
problém efektivněji než klasický algoritmus. Dnes se podíváme na Deutschův algoritmus a
na pozdější rozšíření zvané algoritmus Deutsch-Jozsa a prozkoumáme, jak lze jedinečně kvantové aspekty qubitů
použít ve prospěch kvantového počítače. Pak tyto algoritmy spustíme na reálném kvantovém počítači s Qiskit.
Existují i jiné kvantové algoritmy, které také vykazují teoretickou výhodu oproti known klasickým algoritmům. A ne všechny z nich fungují
na stejných principech jako ty, které uvidíme dnes. Takže to, co se dnes naučíme, nevysvětluje obecně, jak kvantový
počítač funguje, ale pomáhá nám začít vidět, jak lze principy kvantové mechaniky kombinovat k
vytvoření výkonného kvantového počítače. Než se ponoříme do Deutschova algoritmu, zamysleme se nejprve nad tím, jak se kvantové počítače
liší od klasických počítačů a jak by nám to mohlo dát výhodu při řešení určitých
problémů. Jeden rozdíl je v tom, že kvantové bity zvané qubitů mohou být v superpozičních stavech. Místo toho, aby byly
omezeny buď na stav nula nebo na stav jedna, jako je klasický bit, může qubit
být v superpozičním stavu obou nuly a jedničky. Tento stav zapisujeme
takto, kde a a b jsou komplexní čísla, jejichž druhé mocniny se sčítají na jedničku, a čím více
qubitů, tím více se tato propast rozšiřuje. Dva bity mohou být stále jen v jednom z těchto
čtyř možných stavů: 0 0, 1 0, 0 1 nebo 1
1. Dva qubitů mohou být v superpozici všech čtyř z těchto klasicky povolených stavů, což je
zapsáno takto. Obecně klasický systém n bitů může být vždy pouze v jedné z 2 na n možných
kombinací nul a jedniček. Kvantový systém n qubitů může být v superpozici všech 2 na n těchto
stavů. Škálování je exponenciální. Takže i kdybychom měli jen 10 qubitů, mohly by
být v superpozičním stavu 2 na 10, což je 1 024 možných kombinací nul a
jedniček. Toto exponenciální škálování stavového prostoru qubitů se nazývá kvantový
paralelismus a je částečně zodpovědné za výhodu kvantových počítačů nad klasickými počítači. Ale kvantový
počítač není jen masivní paralelní procesor. Jen proto, že qubitů v kvantovém počítači mohou být v
superpozici exponenciálně mnoha stavů, neznamená, že máme přístup ke všem informacím v každém z těchto
stavů. Protože měření zhroutí systém do jednoho stavu nebo druhého, podívejme se,
jak se to projeví v jednoduchém problému. Řekněme, že existuje nějaký stroj, kterému
můžeš podat jeden bit. Poté aplikuje nějakou funkci na tento bit a vyplivne jiný jeden bit. Stroj
je uvnitř černé skříňky, ke které nemáme přístup. Přístup máme pouze k bitu,
který mu podáme – x – a k bitu, který skříňka vyplivne – f
z x. Chceme zjistit, jaká je funkce f, kterou stroj aplikuje.
Existují čtyři možné funkce, které zobrazují jeden bit na jiný jeden bit.
Abychom zjistili, jaká funkce to je, můžeme jí prostě podat nulu a uvidíme, jestli vyplivne nulu nebo jedničku. Pak ji podáme
jedničku a uděláme totéž. Každý z těchto dvou kroků se nazývá dotaz. To je
jeden způsob, jak porovnat klasické a kvantové algoritmy prostřednictvím tzv. modelu dotazů, kde porovnáváme počet
dotazů, které každý z algoritmů musí položit černé skříňce, aby vyřešil problém. Takže v tomto případě naše
klasická metoda potřebovala skříňku dvakrát dotázat, aby se naučila funkci. Podívejme se, zda to dokážeme lépe, pokud budeme mít kvantový
počítač, který se černé skříňky dotáže. Místo toho, abychom nejprve podali nulu a pak jedničku,
může kvantový počítač podat skříňce qubit, který je v superpozici nuly a
jedničky. Takže v podstatě podáváme skříňce oba vstupy jediným dotazem. Pak
to znamená, že funkci zjistíme s jediným dotazem?
Bohužel to tak není. Proč tato myšlenka selže, vidíme, když ji otestujeme na kvantovém počítači. Vytvoříme
circuit se dvěma qubitů. Qubit nula, znázorněný zde touto horní linkou, bude náš vstupní stav X, který podáváme
černé skříňce, zobrazené zde hnědočerveným gate označeným UF. Gate UF je
navržen tak, aby jako vstupní stav X přijal qubit nula a pak aplikoval transformaci na qubit jedna, která zobrazí
stav nula na stav f(x). Takže pokud qubit 1 začal ve stavu
nula, pak výstupem je x na qubitu 0 a f(x) na qubitu 1. Abychom tedy zjistili f(x) pro
x=0 i x=1 současně, můžeme zkusit dát qubit 0 do superpozice 0 a 1 předtím,
než ho podáme černé skříňce. To se provede tímto červeným Hadamard gate, který transformuje stav nula na 1/√2
|0⟩ + |1⟩. Takže po gate černé skříňky bychom nyní měli mít superpozici obou
f(0) a f(1) na qubitu 1. Když měříme dva qubitů, doufáme, že zodpovíme
otázku: jaká funkce je uvnitř černé skříňky? Použijme primitiv sampler z Qiskit ke spuštění
circuit a vrácení výsledku. Počet spuštění circuit – nazývaný vzorky – můžeme zvolit změnou tohoto
parametru nazývaného shots.
WEBVTT
To odpovídá počtu dotazů, které klademe černé skříňce. Uvidíme, jestli bude stačit jen jeden dotaz.
Zde je výsledek. Naměřili jsme qubit 0 jako nula – to byla vstupní hodnota x – a qubit 1 jako 1,
což byla výstupní hodnota f(x). Nyní tedy
víme, že f(0) = 1. Ale co f(1)? Zde leží problém. Jakmile jsme
stav změřili, superpozice se zhroutily a podařilo se nám změřit pouze část funkce jediným
dotazem. To nám neříká vše, co potřebujeme vědět k určení, jaká funkce to je. K tomu bychom potřebovali
druhý dotaz na skříňku. Takže i přestože nám princip kvantového paralelismu umožňuje současně
nechat černou skříňku vyhodnotit f(0) i f(1), nemáme přístup k oběma
těmto odpovědím. Kvantový paralelismus samotný nestačí. Deutschův algoritmus
ukazuje, jak můžeme kvantový paralelismus využít trochu jinak k zjištění o funkci uvnitř černé skříňky. Nedokážeme
přesně zjistit, jaká je funkce, ale dokážeme se o ní jediným dotazem dozvědět něco nového,
co bychom s klasickým počítačem nedokázali. Začněme pohledem na tabulku čtyř možných
funkcí zobrazujících jeden bit na jiný jeden bit. Zde vidíš, že dvě z funkcí – f_sub_1 a f_sub_4 – vždy
vrátí jedinou hodnotu bez ohledu na vstupní stav. Tyto dvě funkce
nazýváme konstantní. f_sub_2 a f_sub_3 vrátí buď nulu nebo jedničku v závislosti na
stavu x. Tyto dvě funkce nazýváme vyvážené. Deutschův algoritmus
určuje, zda je funkce konstantní nebo vyvážená, provedením chytrých úprav circuit, který jsme
použili dříve. Zde je circuit. Začíná přípravou qubitu 0 ve stavu 1/√2
|0⟩ + |1⟩ pomocí Hadamard jako dříve a qubitu 1 ve stavu 1/√2 |0⟩ - |1⟩
pomocí NOT gate následovaného Hadamard.
Takže celý stav v tomto bodě je zde – toto je stav qubitu 0 a
toto je stav qubitu 1. Příprava qubitu 1 tímto způsobem spíše než pouhým
ponecháním ve stavu nula umožňuje algoritmu využívat kvantový paralelismus v kombinaci s interferenci k zjišťování
o funkci černé skříňky. Podívejme se jak. Když jsou qubitů podány do UF – gate černé skříňky – mohou se stát dvě věci.
Pokud je funkce konstantní, černá skříňka provede určitou operaci na qubitu 1 samotném bez ohledu
na stav nuly. V tomto případě, protože UF se qubitu nula nedotýká ani
se nestará o jeho stav vůbec, druhý Hadamard zde jednoduše ruší to, co
udělal první Hadamard. A qubit naměříme ve stavu nula. Podívejme se na vyváženou funkci f_sub_2 jako příklad, abychom viděli,
co UF udělá se stavem v tomto případě. Když je x nula, f(x) je nula a když je x
1, f(x) je 1. Vzpomeň, co jsem ti řekla o gate UF. Přijme qubit 0
jako náš vstupní stav x a vydá f(x) na qubitu 1 – za předpokladu, že qubit 1
začal ve stavu nula. Takže pro tuto funkci to, co UF udělá s qubitm 1, závisí
na qubitu 0. Pokud je 0 nula, pak qubit 1 bude ponechán ve stavu nula, abychom dostali f(x)=0.
Pokud je qubit 0 1, černá skříňka aplikuje NOT gate na qubit 1 a dá mu
stav jedna. Takže dostaneme f(1) = 1. To je přesně to, co dělá kontrolovaný NOT neboli CNOT gate.
CNOT gate přijme dva qubitů – kontrolní qubit a cílový qubit – a překlápí
stav cílového qubitu, pokud je kontrolní qubit ve stavu jedna. Ale cílovému qubitu nedělá nic, pokud je kontrolní
qubit ve stavu nula. Takže UF pro F2 je jen CNOT na Q0 a Q1. CNOT
gate neudělá nic prvnímu členu, protože kontrolní qubit je ve stavu nula. Ale v druhém členu tato
nula se překlopí na jedničku a tato jednička se překlopí na nulu. A pokud vytkneme záporné znaménko, uvidíme, že stav qubitu 1 je
nezměněn. Ale tento člen nabyl záporné znaménko. Takže stav qubitu 0 je
ve skutečnosti ten, který se změnil. Šel od 0 + 1 na 0 mínus
1. Když aplikujeme finální Hadamard na qubit 0, transformuje ho do stavu 1. Takže pokud je funkce v černé skříňce
f_sub_2, naměříme jedničku místo nuly. Ukazuje se, že gate UF pro druhou vyváženou funkci f3 je
stejný CNOT gate následovaný NOT na qubitu 1. Tento finální NOT gate neovlivňuje qubit nula. Takže když je funkce
vyvážená, naměříme qubit 0 ve stavu jedna na konci circuit. Pokud jsi to vše nesledoval,
to je v pořádku. Doporučuji ti to projít sám, abys viděl, jak to funguje. Hlavním bodem zde je to, co se
stalo, když jsme aplikovali CNOT pro dvě vyvážené funkce. Qubit 0 byl použit pouze jako kontrolní qubit ke změně
stavu qubitu 1. Intuitivně bys mohl myslet, že qubit 0 zůstane nezměněn. A přesto naše
operace na qubitu 1 skutečně mění stav qubitu nula změnou relativní fáze mezi dvěma částmi
jeho superpozice. Tento jev je znám jako mechanismus fázového zpětného rázu a je
super kontraintuitivní – jako mnoho kvantových jevů. Jistým způsobem si můžeš mechanismus fázového zpětného rázu
představit jako veslování na lodi. Akt tlačení vody dozadu tě ve skutečnosti pohání vpřed – stejně jako operace na
qubitu 1 skutečně mění qubit nula. Nyní můžeme spustit Deutschův algoritmus na
Qiskit. Zde si můžeme vybrat, jakou funkci dáme do černé skříňky – my jsme zvolili F3. Zde je
circuit diagram algoritmu a můžeme ho spustit jako dříve s primitivem sampler. Nastavíme počet
vzorků na pouhou jedničku a uvidíme, co naměříme. V tomto případě jsme naměřili jedničku.
Takže víme, že funkce byla vyvážená – což bylo skutečně to, co jsme očekávali, protože černá skříňka obsahovala funkci f3. Takže jediným
dotazem jsme dokázali rozlišit mezi těmito dvěma třídami funkcí.
Klasický algoritmus by k tomu potřeboval dva dotazy. To ukazuje skromnou výhodu kvantové
výpočetní techniky oproti klasické výpočetní technice – ale není to příliš impozantní. Jen jedna místo dvou. Ale Deutschův algoritmus
WEBVTT
je stále nesmírně důležitý pro historii kvantové výpočetní techniky, protože poskytl jiskru, která přivedla ostatní
k přemýšlení o větších, sofistikovanějších kvantových algoritmech.
To zahrnuje multiqubitové rozšíření Deutschova algoritmu, které demonstruje mnohem impozantnější kvantovou výhodu.
To se nazývá algoritmus Deutsch-Jozsa. Řeší podobný problém, ale v tomto případě funkce v černé skříňce,
o které se chceme dozvědět, přijímá n bitů jako vstup a vydává jeden bit. Jak
dříve, je nám zaručeno, že funkce je buď konstantní – což znamená, že výstupní bit je vždy jedna nebo vždy nula
bez ohledu na vstupní řetězec bitů – nebo vyvážená – což znamená, že výstup je nula pro
polovinu vstupních řetězců bitů a jedna pro druhou polovinu. Samozřejmě existují i jiné
funkce, které zobrazují n bitů na jeden bit a nejsou ani konstantní ani vyvážené. Ale v tomto problému nám
je zaručeno, že žádná z těchto funkcí není uvnitř černé skříňky. Ta v ní je zaručeně buď konstantní
nebo vyvážená. Circuit Deutsch-Jozsa vypadá podobně jako Deutschův algoritmus, ale s více qubitů. Zde máme
implementaci algoritmu Deutsch-Jozsa k zjišťování o tříbitové funkci. Tentokrát máme tři qubitů
pro vstupní stav místo jen jednoho. A pak máme tento poslední qubit pro výstupní stav. Jako dříve
připravíme všechny vstupní qubitů do stavu |0⟩ + |1⟩ a výstupní qubit
do stavu |0⟩ - |1⟩. Pak – i když matematika je o něco složitější –
princip zůstává stejný. Pokud je funkce konstantní, nebude vůbec záviset na horních třech qubitech. Takže jejich stavy
se po druhých Hadamardech transformují zpět na nulu a naše měření vydá tříbitový řetězec samých
nul. Ale pokud je funkce vyvážená, pak když qubitů měříme po Hadamardech, mechanismus fázového zpětného rázu
způsobí, že jeden nebo více z těchto bitů bude jedna. To nemusí být tentokrát tak snadné vidět, ale pokud si
každý krok projdeš sám, brzy uvidíš, že to tak musí být. Jedním způsobem, jak to ověřit, je pokusit se vypočítat
pravděpodobnost naměření samých nul s vyváženou funkcí. Měl bys dostat pravděpodobnost nula. Spusťme
algoritmus Deutsch-Jozsa na kvantovém počítači s Qiskit. Nejtěžší krok je pravděpodobně vytvoření funkce Deutsch-Jozsa.
To bude naše černá skříňka, na kterou se zde dotazujeme. Tento kód produkuje náhodnou funkci Deutsch-Jozsa, která je
zaručeně buď vyvážená nebo konstantní. Pak vytvoříme náš circuit Deutsch-Jozsa vložením naší funkce černé skříňky
zde. Opět spustíme circuit se samplerem a po naměření se podíváme na
naměřené bity, abychom určili, zda byla funkce vyvážená nebo konstantní.
Pokud jsou všechny nuly, je konstantní. Pokud je v řetězci alespoň jedna jednička, pak je vyvážená. V tomto
případě dostaneme řetězec bitů 1 1 1.
Takže víme, že funkce byla vyvážená. Doufám, že jsem ti dal první pohled na to, jak kvantové algoritmy
mohou využívat zajímavých a often jemných kvantových jevů k získání výhody nad klasickými
algoritmy. Pravděpodobně jsi také zaznamenal, jak složité může být navrhovat kvantové algoritmy. Dokonce i ten úplně první
vyžadoval hodně kreativity k dosažení jen skromného vítězství nad klasickými metodami. A od tohoto prvního algoritmu
fyzikové a informatici stále vymýšlejí neuvěřitelně vynalézavé způsoby, jak využívat kvantovou mechaniku
ve svůj prospěch – včetně dalších rozšíření a aplikací algoritmu Deutsch-Jozsa. Pokud se chceš
o některých z nich dozvědět, stejně jako vyzkoušet algoritmy Deutsch a Deutsch-Jozsa sám,
přejdi do modulu odkazovaného v popisu a začni. Díky za sledování a uvidíme se příště.